[Music]
hi how are you good good how you doing
hey Francis Serrano is a young man who
knows he's at risk for a heart attack
when I was a young boy people always
said that you know what by the time
you're 20 you're gonna have a heart
attack and you could be dead
well I'm 28 now so what I'm afraid of is
that I'm on borrowed time francis weighs
more than 500 pounds and that's who i am
i a morbidly obese where is almost a
certain that i will die because of my
weight problem
how did francis get to the point where
he weighs this much for some people
weight gain is caused by hormonal
conditions but for francis a lifetime of
overeating and lack of exercise resulted
in his massive body if you take fuel in
if you take food you can either burn it
or you can store it and the storage is
sort of like a battery you can run your
battery out but you have to have a place
to store that energy and thus fat cells
are where you store that energy you take
carbohydrate you can take protein and if
you don't need it for fuel you turn it
into fat you're a little bit forward
Circulo and exercise a good strategy for
weight loss strains the heart and lungs
of an obese person
[Music]
too much for me Joe it's very
frustrating because I want to do more I
want to do so much more but my body is
the one telling me you know I got slowed
down here and slow it down but I'm
running out of time in order to quicken
his weight-loss Francis has opted for a
radical solution a gastric bypass
surgery basically what they're gonna do
is make my stomach the size of a shot
glass and then reconnect my my-my-my
intestines to that to the new portion of
my my smaller stomach gastric bypass is
the most common operation performed in
u.s. for weight loss I think right now
we have it down to an art form our
complication rates are very low the
outcomes are excellent I think it's here
to stay
[Music]
it's still considered a risky operation
with one in 100 operations ending in
death for Francis we thought the
worldwide gastric bypass is the best
operation it has a consistent weight
loss in the first year statistically
patients lose approximately 70 to 80% of
your excess body weight so right now
we're gonna go ahead and close the
incisions that we made and we're done
with the operation afternoon everybody
there's something that I like to share
with you guys today I underwent gastric
bypass surgery after one a month Francis
has recovered from surgery and is much
trimmer even so this surgery is not a
miracle if Francis doesn't change his
lifestyle he won't continue to lose
weight and could even gain some back I
wanted to continue to enjoy life Francis
is feeling very optimistic that he'll be
able to make the necessary changes he
knows he has a lot to live for
I don't plan to be a bodybuilder I just
want to be healthy I just want to be
able to enjoy life
[Music]